Bitte schön.
Okay. Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Ady Güzel. Ich bin der dienzhafende Arzt und werde jetzt das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihrem führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir, falls Sie meiner Worte nicht perstechen sollten.
Als erstes werde ich Ihnen ein paar generelle Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Guten Abend. Hallo.
Hallo.
Wir sind ein junger Arzt hier, ja?
Ja.
Junger Arzt. Ja, das freut mich.
Gebacken Arzt.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Martin Brandt.
Brandt. Entschuldigung, die HW leider nicht verstanden können Sie.
Martin ist mein Vorname Martin, M-A-R-T-I-N.
T-N.
Martin ist Vorname, Nachname ist Brandt.
Brandt.
Richard, B-R-A-B-Anton, N-W-Nordpol, D-V-Dora und T-V-T-O-Dora. Brandt. Das ist der Nachname von mir.
Danke schön, Frau Herr Brandt.
Ja, wollen Sie?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. April 1969.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,73 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege ca. 100 kg.
Entschuldigung?
100 kg.
Okay. Erzählen Sie mal Herr Brandt,
warum führen Sie heute so?
Also Herr Doktor, ich weiß nicht, was es ist,
aber ich habe seit 3 Tagen starke Schmerzen auf der Brust.
Und ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, mir sitzt ein großer Elefant auf der Brust.
Ich bekomme schlecht Luft und es wird von Tag zu Tag immer schlimmer.
Okay. Können Sie mir öfter sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Hier vorne auf der Brust, das verteilt sich so ein bisschen über der Brust.
Okay. Schmerzen strahlen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Ja, seit heute habe ich das Gefühl, es strahlt mir in den Reis und in den linken Schulter.
Seit wann haben Sie die Beschwerden?
Seit 3 Tagen.
3 Tagen.
Haben die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich angefangen?
Nein, die Schmerzen haben langsam angefangen und sind jetzt stärker geworden.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben, sind die Schmerzen zum Beispiel dunf, sterben, drücken?
Das ist so ein Druckgefühl.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalaform 1 bis 10, wenn 1 sehr leicht und sehr stark ist?
Ich würde sagen, vor 2 Tagen war es so um die 3 und heute ist es schon bei 7,8.
Wie haben sich die Beschwerden im Verlauf beantragt?
Nein, die Schmerzen sind schlimmer geworden.
Wann treten die Schmerzen bei Belastung oder bei der Belastung?
Vor einigen Wochen war es immer bei Belastung, aber jetzt dauerhaft.
Dauerhaft.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder nicht?
Jetzt sind Sie dauerhaft, jetzt sind Sie immer da.
Nein.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, wie zum Beispiel Fibre, Karbraham?
Nein, habe ich nicht, aber ich habe eine leichte Übelkeit.
Fibre kommt.
Ist Luftmutter aufgetreten?
Ich würde nicht sagen, aber mit dem Druck zusammen habe ich auch eine Übelkeit.
Jetzt werde ich fragen zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen und Medikamentenstellen.
Sie sind uns wichtig.
Haben Sie wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe seit drei Jahren einen Diabetes.
Seit über zehn Jahren schon einen hohen Blutdruck, da nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Seit wann besteht Blutdruck?
Seit über zehn Jahren.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Die Gallenblase wurde vor fünf Jahren rausgenommen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder delegativ Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich.
Für den Blutdruck nehme ich Medikamente ein und für den Diabetes.
Welche Medikamente?
Für den Blutdruck habe ich Ramipri, fünf Milligramm und Amnodipin, zehn Milligramm.
Für den Diabetes habe ich Medformin.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, mein Haushalt hat erst vor Kurzem die Impfungen durchgeguckt.
Die Impfungen sind komplett.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Verlassen?
Nein, nein, ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unfalltreckigkeits?
Ja, wenn Sie mich so fragen, ich habe Allergien gegen einige Medikamente.
Da ist zum Beispiel Novalgin.
Novalgin ist ein Medikament.
Dann habe ich gegen Aspirin und gegen Penezebin.
Wie aussagt sich die allergische Reaktion?
Allergische Reaktion, meinen Sie.
Ich bekomme mir Schwillt der Heils, Herzparasen, Ausschlag am Körper.
Mein Kreislauf kriegt Probleme.
Ich würde gerne etwas über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten erfahren.
Na, Doktor, wie lange wollen Sie mich noch fragen?
Ich habe die Schmerzen, die werden schlimmer,
wollen Sie dagegen etwas tun oder fragen Sie mich über die ganze Zeit?
Ich bekomme Schmerzen, ich bekomme Schmerzen, ich bekomme Schmerzen, ich bekomme Schmerzen, ich bekomme Schmerzen.
ganz schlecht Luft, der Dr. Druck, der ist ganz stark.
Ja, jetzt werde ich sie so nach Smittern sich hinflügen, um eine EKG machen.
Ah, das ist eine gute Idee, bitte.
Geben Sie mir auch ein bisschen Luft, ein bisschen Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff?
Luft durch die Nase.
Ja, ja.
Bitte.
Schrauben Sie den Raub?
Nicht schrauben.
Tricken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe einen.
Nein.
Ich auch nicht.
Tricken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Ich werde jetzt eine Routine fragen stellen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Gibt es Ihnen Ihre Familie wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Leben Ihr Alter noch?
Ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Was machen Sie denn beruflich?
Ich bin Schreiner.
Schreiner, bitte.
Schreiner, Marangos.
Schreiner.
Herr Brandt, das waren erstmal alle wichtigen Fragen von meinem Herr Brandt.
Danke schön.
Was haben Sie im EKG gesehen?
Sie haben doch gerade eben einen EKG gemacht.
Sie haben einen EKG geschrieben.
Also im EKG siehst du als Doktor eine ST-Hebung in den Ableitungen 2, 3 auf Vf, V3 bis V6.
ST-Hebungen.
Perquenz 90 pro Minute, Blutdruck 100 zu 70.
Was siehst du im EKG?
Was musst du jetzt machen?
ST-ST-Hebungen.
ST-Elevation.
Ja.
Ja, akut es, koronärsandrum.
Mehr ST-Hebungen.
Ja, ja.
Was Labur gemacht, Troponin.
ST-T ist positiv.
Du hast ST-Hebungen. Was machst du mit den Patienten?
Äh, Patienten.
Äh, ja.
Genau, das besprechen wir gleich.
Okay?
Erstmal eine kleine Pause.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Herr Brandt.
Herr Brandt, haben Sie für diese Beschwerden früher ein Arzt besucht?
Nein, das habe ich erst seit 3 Tagen.
Ah, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, einige Woche bei Belastung.
Ja, genau.
Besucht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas diese Beschwerden seit 3 Jahren eingenommen?
Ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Okay, danke.
Noch eine Frage, Kollegen?
Keine Trauze, eine Frage zu stellen.
Profi.
Bitte schön, Anne.
Haben Sie schon einmal Ende des Schmerz und Perspektives?
Ja, also vor 2, 3 Wochen, aber das waren nur ganz kurz.
Okay, ich glaube, das war es, oder?
Ich habe noch Fragen, aber darf ich?
Wer ist das?
Ähm, wir, einen Moment, andere Kollegen.
Ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Husten, Ausflug oder und Schwellung auf dem Bein?
Schwellung an den Beinen?
Nein.
Husten habe ich auch.
Bitte schön, Amra.
Ja, haben Sie eine Herzrasen oder Herzstopern seit 3 Tagen in Amerika?
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, eine Reaktion.
Ich habe einen Luftnot und Herzra.
Okay, danke.
Deswegen Taxidermatik und Schmerz bei Begleitsymptome.
Haben Sie Rückenschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen?
Hoch?
Richtige Bauchschmerzen nicht, aber ist es mehr die Brust?
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Todesgift?
Todesangst.
Todesangst, sorry.
Nein, aber die Schmerzen sind schon sehr, sehr stark, ja.
Also okay, haben Sie Rückenschweiz?
Rückenschmerzen? Nein.
Kalte Schweißigkeit, ich denke.
Kalte Schweißigkeit, ja, ja.
Kalte Schweißigkeit oder Kalte Schweißigkeit, nein.
Noch nicht.
Noch nicht, okay, danke schön.
Sollen wir Übergabe machen?
Ja, ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Könnten wir als erstes jetzt anfangen?
Wo ist unser Dr. Said?
Herr Degüsen.
Guten Abend Herr Oberatz.
Heute haben wir eine neue Patient.
Und ihr Fall möchte ich gerne jetzt mit Ihnen besprechen.
Nicht ihr Fall, sondern den Fall.
Vorstellend.
Guten Abend, Herr junge Kollege aus Belgien.
Hallo, liebe Said.
Hallo.
Willi Brück.
Darf ich Ihnen, so als der Patient, vorstellen?
Das ist der Patient, natürlich.
Den Akkusativ, den Patienten vorstellen.
Sein Name ist...
Ihr ist bei Weiblich, bei Frauen.
Sein Name ist Herr Brandt.
Er ist 55 Jahre alt, 100...
70...
70 groß.
70 groß und 100 kilo schwer.
Der Patient berichtet, dass TOROK-Schmerzen langsam
vor drei Tagen aufgetreten seien.
Retrus-Ternal-Schmerzen.
TOROK-Schmerzen, wo?
Alle TOROK-Schmerzen.
Aber retrus-ternal-Schmerzen, ja.
Und...
Unterküfe und linken Schulter seien.
Herr, nicht unterküfe.
Hals.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den Hals.
Nicht küfe, wie gesagt, der Patient hat.
Genau, in den Hals und in die linke Schulter.
Die Schmerzen seien drückend.
Die Schmerzen-State wurde mit sieben bis acht
von zehn auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Das weitere Berichtete, die Patienten von Überkite.
No idea.
Die Patienten klappen nicht andere Beschwerden.
Nein.
Nein, Herr Herr.
Das andere ist der Patient.
Nein.
Amnodipin, Amipril und Metformin.
Er ist...
Wie viel ist Milligramm, Dosis?
Ja, Amnodipin, 10 Milligramm, Amipril, 5 Milligramm
und Metformin, ich weiß es nicht.
Unbekannte Dosis?
Er rauchert nicht und trinkt keinen.
Er drogt einen Nesefen ein.
Undeternen.
Neuergänz, Wolfgang?
Er bietet zwei Dokumente.
Ok, viele Dokumente.
Anhargisch, alles ist.
Neuling, Anhargisch, ja,
Wie schnell ist das Neuling?
Das ist das Metamizer.
Neuling, Metamizer, GRETS,
Metamizer.
A C S, A S S, A C C ist ein Schleimlöser.
Und penicillin, allergie.
Okay.
Bio-Sersich, Bio-Sersich, die allergie Reaktion.
Ausflug, Ausflug, Exantem.
Exantem, der Haut.
Und Altschwellung.
Okay.
Sozialistisch.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er hat zwei Kinder und gesund.
Er ist schreider.
Schreider.
Er ist unabhängig.
Okay, Verdachtdiagnos und so weiter.
Mein Verdachtdiagnos da tut.
Wir haben aber statt, Sie müssen den Oberhaus auf die EKG berichten.
Sie haben ein EKG.
Sie haben eine Sauerstoffzettigung gemacht.
Sie haben Blutdruck gemessen.
Was kam dabei raus?
Im EKG hat der Patient, oder der Blutdruck war wie viel?
Wie hoch war der Blutdruck?
Nein, nein, Blutdruck.
170, glaube ich.
Ist das normal, gut oder hoch oder niedrig?
Ist es normal?
Nein.
EKG, was hast du im EKG gesehen?
Ich habe es der Hebben gesehen.
In welchen Ableitung?
In welchen Ableitungen?
1, 2, 3,
AVL, AVF,
2, 2, 3, 4.
Es gibt die Extremitätenableitungen
und es gibt die Brustwand-Ableitungen.
Wir haben gesehen im EKG
der Ableitung Römisch 2.
Wir haben gesehen,
in der Ableitung Römisch 2,
in der Ableitung 3 und AVF.
Zusätzlich haben wir Hebungen
in V3 bis V6.
Was bedeutet das für einen?
Nein, nicht im EKG, im EKG.
Wir haben einen Katalog bei uns.
Was ist das, Herr Doktor?
Was haben Sie schon gesagt?
Was ist das für eine Diagnose?
Mein Verdachtdiagnose
ist akutes Myokartinfarkt.
Akutes Myokartinfarkt?
Akutes Coronasendrom,
nicht akutes Myokartinfarkt.
Aber mit Hebungen?
Aber akutes Coronasendrom,
das klassische Method, akutes Coronasendrom.
Drei Teilung, akutes Esteehebung,
non-Esteehebung, instabil an den Effektöpfen.
Aber erst mal akutes Coronasendrom,
müssen wir sagen.
Aber ich dachte, wenn ich eine ganz klare
Veränderung im EKG habe,
dann muss ich das nicht machen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber akutes Coronasendrom,
besonders Esteehemyokartinfarkt.
Aber akutes Coronasendrom
in der FSB, müssen wir nennen.
Ah, okay, gut.
Also ein akutes Coronasendrom
mit hochgradigem Verdacht auf
einen akuten Myokartinfarkt
und auf Grundableitungen
muss man von einem Hinterwand infarkt
ausgehen.
Verdacht ist differenzial diagnostisch.
Dann du versagst, differenzial Diagnose.
Differenzial Diagnose ist
pericarditis.
Eine was? Eine?
Pericarditis.
Pericarditis, okay, ja.
Pulmenarembul.
Eine pulmenarembulie, okay.
Und...
Spontampinamotorax.
Spontan.
Okay.
Alles.
Okay, was denken die Kolleginnen,
woran müssen wir noch denken?
Steigelschnarzen.
Retro-Sternar. Was ist Retro-Sternar für ein Organ?
Oder in der Nähe von Retro-Sternar?
Gut pankratit.
Lauter, bitte.
Gut pankratit. Art-Sektion.
Ja, Art-Sektion, ja.
Ganz einfach, der Magin.
Ja, Akutoptomen.
Gut, das Akutoptomen oder Akutoptitis.
Gastroesophageal reflux.
Jawohl.
Und, was ist neben dem Magin?
Eine Gallenblase.
Aber 12, 10 Jahre, ein Kulisektor.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir lassen jetzt Herrn Saait,
um die Ruhe, oder?
Erst die Frischung.
Am Ende Therapie-Vorschlag.
Und dann fertig.
Ja, stimmt. Das machen wir jetzt. Ein Patient.
Jetzt hast du Doktor Levo-Doktor, ein Patient.
Da siehst du ST-Hebungen, ST-Elevation über der Hinterwand.
Was muss man jetzt mit den Patienten machen?
Doktor, wo bist du?
Was soll das sein?
Der Patient hat jetzt einen Akuten Myocardinfarkt.
Was machst du jetzt mit dem, sagst du?
Wir warten einen Moment, oder?
Soll er morgen nochmal kommen?
PTCA.
Was ist eine PTCA?
Wie nennt man die Untersuchung für eine PTCA?
Ganz einfach.
Auf Deutsch ein Herzkatheter.
Herzkatheter.
Wie heißt der medizinische Begriff dazu?
Eine Corona-Angiografie.
Corona-Angiografie, kennst du das?
Ein Angiografie.
Warum muss man das schnell machen?
Weil der Patient kreislaufinstabil ist.
Ein Blut, der hat einen Angiografie.
Der Patient hat einen Herzinfarkt.
Der ist also kreislaufinstabil.
Man muss ihn sehr schnell in den Herzkatheter Labor bringen.
Immer.
Sehr gut.
Also, akuten Myocardinfarkt.
Dann gleich ins Herzkatheter Labor.
Machen wir einen Punkt.
Herr Doktor, ich habe einen Punkt.
Ich denke alles.